over the weekend our president basically
admitted what many Americans have
thought for a long time which is that he
wasn't really ready nor qualified to be
President of the United States Trump did
an interview with Reuters a few days ago
the entire thing was about as delusional
as that Associated Press interview from
last week let's take a look at a couple
different pieces of it here's Donald
Trump saying quote I loved my previous
life I had so many things going this is
more work than in my previous life I
thought it would be easier I thought it
would be easier to be President of the
United States in other words I didn't
know what the job entailed and it's
shocking that being president of the
United States would be more work than
real estate right or I guess the last 10
years have mostly been being a reality
show host and putting your name on
buildings and also this is more work
than Trump was doing before he's playing
golf every nine days how much more work
is he doing now than before if this is
more work but anyway here we get to the
really delusional part of this interview
quote I thought it was more of a I'm a
details oriented person I think you'd
say that but I do miss my old life I
like to work so that's not a problem but
this is actually more work he says he's
a detail oriented person he released a
tax plan which would represent a massive
total overhaul as a single page of
bullet points and it didn't even explain
Pat what the income limits were for each
of the three tax brackets he proposed
the first bullet point is grow the
economy and create millions of jobs on
what planet is this guy detail-oriented
and just the fact that he didn't realize
that the presidency is perhaps the
hardest job in the entire world because
there's so much pressure on you and
ideally you should be working around the
clock in that role it kind of reminds me
of a few weeks ago when the Republican
health care bill was being debated and
he said that no one new health care
could be so complicated everyone knows
that health care is complicated everyone
knows that the presidency is a hard job
yeah it seems as mostly Trump who
doesn't know these off
Truths and and again detail-oriented
whenever Trump is asked any question by
reporters the guy can't go two sentences
before interrupting himself Americans by
and large agree that Donald Trump is not
qualified to be President of the United
States and Trump is sort of in a way
coming around to that many polls told us
this all election long we had a
Washington post/abc News poll which came
out which showed us that by and large
Americans thought throughout 2015 and
2016 that Trump wasn't qualified to be
President we had a CBS News poll from
2016 which again showed that a majority
of Americans did not think that Donald
Trump was qualified to be President and
the details show more of the delusions
that Donald Trump has here in the middle
of his interview with Reuters
Trump passed out copies of a map he had
on hand was this a map of his foreign
policy strategy was this a map of the
broader strategy in Syria
no Donald Trump handed out a map during
this Reuters interview which was colored
in with the results of the 2016 election
saying to the Reuters team it's pretty
good right this guy is so obsessed with
the election results that he keeps
printouts of the results map around to
show visitors we're dealing with a child
here and here's the best way I think to
sum it up path Trump's goal was never to
be President it was to win the
presidential election we're learning now
how major the differences are between
those two things Trump wanted the trophy
not the job and that's why he's keeping
around the election maps you don't
actually get a trophy when you win the
presidential election and the closest
thing is these maps that Trump is
handing to people I think that just
given Donald Trump's skill set it was a
lot easier for him to be a campaigner to
speak in front of large crowds to
downplay people like lying Ted and
crooked Hillary but now that he's in a
position where he actually has to be
detail-oriented and be a good president
it's a much more challenging task for
him yeah it's not nearly as fun and I
would blame Obama actually I mean Obama
should
campaigned harder for Hillary Clinton in
the Rust Belt so that people would
realize Trump wasn't ready as with
everything else I think that we have a
really solid case here to blame former
President Barack Obama